this is session seven of the foundations
and finance module
and in this session i'd like to take
what we talked about last session which
is the time value of money and applied
in valuing a contractual claim in a
contractual claim here's what you have
at the time the contract is entered into
your you're told what the cash flows
will be over the lifetime of the
contract
the cash flows are set at the time of
the contract those cash flows can be
fixed fixed in what sense 50 million a
year every year for the next 10 years
20 a year for the next 10 years that is
what you get with a fixed rate
a loan or a or a traditional fixed rate
bond
the cash flow could be variable over
time but the terms of variance are set
again at the time of the contract
that's the case with a floating rate
loan in a floating rate loan i might
tell you that i will pay one percent
more than inflation each year for the
next 10 years
my cash flows will vary across time but
they will vary in a contractually set
way
each year i'll observe the inflation and
add one percent to it
they're both contractual claims the
first is a little easier to think about
than than the second
but let's start by first introducing the
notion of default risk
remember in a contract the promisor is
promising to pay you the cash flows in
the contract
but promises don't always deliver on
their promises
if the promisor has no default risk the
claim
is said to be a risk-free claim you're
saying what kind of promise has no
default risk
the only type of promise who is a chance
of not having default risk
is a government why because governments
can print currency
that said not all government claims are
risk-free
so while all risk-free claims have to be
issued by governments not all government
claims are risk-free
the second sounds mysterious think about
a claim from the argentine government
the venezuelan government the greek
government
clearly these are government bonds
issued but they're not risk-free
now if there is default risk things get
a little messy we have to adjust the
value of the bond for default risk but
let's take the easy scenario first
let's think about valuing a fixed rate
risk-free bond
to value a fixed rate risk-free bond
here's what i'm going to do
i'm going to discount the coupons and
the face value of the bond
which are known at the time that i do
the valuation at the risk-free rate
so i'll take an example let's assume the
us government is default free it has to
be an assumption because there are no
guarantees
let's assume you're trying to price a a
u.s government bond with 10 years left
to maturity and a three percent coupon
rate
this one could have been issued 10 15 20
years ago but there are only ten years
left on it it's got a three percent
coupon rate
let's assume that the market interest
rate today on a 10-year
us treasury bond is two percent that's a
market risk
that's a risk-free rate today so here's
what i'm going to do to value to spawn
i'm going to take the coupons which are
three percent of face value and bonds
are conventionally priced
on a thousand dollar face value so it's
30 a year for the next 10 years
and i'm going to take the thousand
dollar face value face value at the end
and i'm going to discount them all back
at my current market interest rate of 2
i've used the notation i've created for
time value which is i'm trying to
compute the present value of an annuity
the 30
is an annuity with a 10-year period and
a 2
interest rate and i get the present
value of the coupon so the first term in
this equation is the present value of
the coupons
the second term is the present value of
the face value
what i get is the sum of those two
numbers is
point eight 1089.83 that would be the
value of the bond today
just as an aside i've cheated here and
here's how i've cheated
usually when bonds pay coupons i pay
them every six months at least in the
u.s so if i were a purist here i should
really have been
taking fifteen dollars every six months
rather than thirty dollars every year
that would have altered my value a
little bit but i to keep things simple
i'm gonna act like the coupons ran
this bond is described often as trading
at above par
you're saying what's part par is a
thousand dollars that's a face value
it's trading above par there's no
mystery why it's trading above par
it's trading above par because the
market interest rate on this bond is
less than the coupon rate
if the market interest rate had been
higher than the coupon rate
it would be trading at a discount if
market interest rates were equal to the
coupon rate
the bond will trade at par now having
priced
that bond let's do a few what-ifs
let's assume that after you've bought
this bond
um you let's assume that after you
bought about the month
a day later you look at the price and
the price is down to 1043.76
so you know the price of the bond is
dropped and you want to know what
interest rate is embedded in that price
this is when you compute what's called
the yield to maturity in a bond sounds
fancy but the yield to maturity is that
discount rate
that makes the present value of your
coupons and the face value equal to the
price of the bond it's an internal rate
of return
so in this case here's the setup i know
the price of the bond is one thousand
and forty three point seven six
since it's only one day and i still have
thirty dollars in coupons
every every year for the next ten years
and a thousand at the end of the tenth
year
i solve for r and i solve for r
the discount rate that i get is two
point five percent
you're saying what does that mean that
is the market interest rate remember
yesterday was two percent
the rates went from two to two and a
half percent the price of my bond not
surprisingly
dropped from 1089 plus to 1043.76
now there is a related concept called
yield as opposed to yield to maturity
yield on a bond is a far simpler measure
here's what you do when you compute the
yield on a bond you divide the coupon to
thirty dollars
by the price of the bond you get two
point eight seven percent
notice that the yield and the yield to
maturity move in the same direction but
the yield to maturity is a more precise
measure of the actual rate of return
you're making of the bond but it does
require more work to get there
now building further on this concept
let's introduce another notion
let me go back to the 3 10-year coupon
bond that we valued at 1043.76 that was
based on a two and a half percent
interest rate right
now let's assume that market interest
rates go from two and a half to three
and a half percent
remember if interest rates go up the
present value of the coupons
the face value will drop but not
surprisingly the bond price
drops from 1043.76 to 958.41
that's an 8.18 drop in the price you
think so what
hang in there if instead of going up
interest rates had gone down from two
from two and a half percent to one and a
half percent a one percent drop in
interest rates
well the bond is going to get more
valuable in this case the bond price
will jump to one thousand one thirty
eight point three three which is an
increase of 9.06 percent
you still might be wondering so what a
one percent increase in interest rates
caused my price to drop by 8.18
a one percent drop in interest rates
caused my price to go up by 9.06 percent
my percentage change in price when rates
drop by
a fixed amount was much greater than the
percentage change in price when my when
rates went up by that same amount
that's called bond convexity it's
neither here nor that you're saying so
what but if you here talk about bond
convexity it's talking about this
this specific aspect of bonds and how
the price of a bond adjusts to interest
rates
so let's introduce a couple of
propositions that come from this present
value equation
as i extend the maturity of a bond it is
going to get more sensitive to changes
in interest rates
i'll show you the numbers first and then
we'll talk about the intuition later
here i have a one-year bond a five-year
bond a ten-year bond and thirty-year-old
they're all corporate
they're all u.s treasury bonds and in
each case i've taken a two and a half
percent market interest rate and changed
to three and a half and a one and one
and a half
percent apiece and looked at the
percentage change in price with a
30-year bond a 20-year bond ten
a five-year and a one-year so if you
look at the 30-year bond
notice that for that when when rates go
down and rates go up the percentage
change in price is much greater than for
a 10-year bond
which in turn is much greater than for a
five-year bond which in turn is much
greater than for a one year bond
you should get the intuition right the
reason this is happening is time value
of money
with the third year bond my big cash
flow which is my face value is way out
in the future so if interest rate change
the effect of those changes
is much greater okay so the longer the
maturity of a bond the more sensitive is
it is going to be to changes in interest
rates long-term bonds will be affected
by interest rate changes by
by a given interest rate change more
than a short-term bond
here's my second proposition holding all
that's constant if i make my coupon rate
lower
my bond price is going to get more
sensitive to interest rate changes
here for instance i've graphed out five
different coupon rates actually six
different coupon rates ranging from zero
percent to five percent
at a zero percent coupon rate i
basically have a zero coupon bond you're
saying what do i even get with a zero
coupon but
if it's a ten year bond you get nothing
for the next ten years and at the end of
the tenth you get the thousand dollars
back
number one percent of two percent three
percent see what's happening here as i
raise my coupon rate
i am front-ending my cash flows a little
bit more
and the effect of changing interest
rates is smaller on me
so as my coupon rate goes up i will get
less sensitive to interest rate changes
so the longer the maturity of a bond the
more sensitive i'm going to be the
interest rate changes
the lower the coupon rate on my bond the
more sensitive the price is going to be
to interest rate changes
now let's introduce the notion of
default risk it is true that when
the contract is written the promise
agrees to pay you what's in the contract
but
if you have a promise who can default
clearly you will not pay as much for
that same bond than for an equivalent
bond with no default risk
so the question is how do you bring that
risk into the process
the risk that you will not be paid your
coupons in your face values
often described as default risk or
credit risk
and here's how bond pricing works
you still when you try to value bond
keep the promised cash flows you're
saying that's so hopelessly unrealistic
hang in there
i use the same promise cash flows
knowing fully well that i might not get
paid
but when i discount those cash flows i
discount them back not at the risk-free
rate
but at a rate that reflects both the
risk-free rate and the default risk that
i have
and the additional amount that i will
add to the risk-free rate to cover the
default risk is called the default
spread
sounds abstract right but let's make
this real by looking at
measures of default risk until about 100
years ago
banks were the only entities that
assessed the fortress to decide whether
to lend money and was a secretive
process that you couldn't look into
about a hundred years ago the first
ratings agencies showed up primarily
because people wanted to buy bonds
and these people couldn't do the same
kind of assessment that banks did
so the very first ratings agencies s p
and moody's
attached letter grade ratings for bonds
and the ratings range from
aaa down to d a triple a bond is
considered to be the lowest default risk
now you are trusting ratings agencies
when you take the rating of a bond but
to the extent that
ratings agencies do their homework this
becomes a proxy for default risk
so the default spread is what you charge
based on the default score bond so
in january 2017 for instance if you
bought a triple a
rated bond that is considered the safest
among
the corporate bonds the spread you'd
have charged is 0.6 percent what does
that mean if the risk-free rate is two
and a half percent or 2.25 percent
you would add the 0.6 percent to reflect
the fact that there's default risk in
the bond
so to price a triple a rated bond you
take the coupons in the bond and
discount it back
at an interest rate that included the
0.6 percent if you're born with a triple
b
rated bond the spread in 2017 would have
been one point six percent
so here's what you do you take the
risk-free rate you'd add one point six
percent to it
and essentially discount the coupons and
the face value back
at that rate and if it were a triple c
rated bond which is even higher risk you
take six and a half percent which is the
default
so essentially what's happening is your
the rate you're charging
will get raised based on the default
risk and the more default risk there is
the higher the discount rate you will
use to discount those promise coupons
and
and face value and what you get as a
value for the bond will already reflect
default risk
so let's try this out let's assume that
you're trying to value a bond with
default rates let's make it a triple b
rated three percent coupon rate ten-year
corporate bond
let's say it's january 2017 let's say
the risk-free rate is 2.5 percent
and let's say the default spread is 1.75
it's really 1.6 but let's say it was
1.75
so 2.5 plus one point seven five percent
gives me a discount rate of four point
two five percent
i still have the thirty dollar coupon of
the thousand dollar face value because
that's determined by the coupon rate and
the face value
i discount the coupons and the face
value back at four and a quarter percent
what i get as a present value is 899
dollars and 87 cents that is the value a
triple b
rated coupon a triple b rated bond with
a 3
coupon rate the mechanics of pricing
a default of a bond with default risk
are no different than the mechanics of
pricing
a risk-free bond the number that's going
to change
is the discount rate that you're using
rather than use the risk free rate
you'll add the risk-free rate to the
default spread
and that then becomes the basis for for
valuing
any contractual claim that has default
risk in it
now if you take a closer look at that
equation you can see that the value of a
corporate bond is going to be a function
of how much default risk you see in the
bond
so that bond that is rated triple b if
tomorrow you woke up and discovered that
the company had done something awful and
it's rating it dropped a single b
the default spread will widen the
interest rate will go up and even though
the coupon and the face value stay the
same the price of the bond will drop
incidentally if your rating drops below
triple b you're considered below
investment grade triple b is the
dividing line between investment grade
bonds and non-investment grade
and it goes back to history there was a
point in time where only investment
grade bonds could issue bonds into
market so
that magical line still remains and many
companies
blanch at the thought of dropping below
investment grade but if you're
if your rating drops below triple b you
go to double b
single b the rate the interest rates on
those bonds will go up and you're
classified as high yield bonds again
a classification class for any bonds
that are below investment grade
now just as an aside on floating rate
points you're saying how do i do this
if a floating rate bond is set right in
other words the interest rate each
period is reset to the market interest
rate that year
it's like a collection of short-term
bonds at the fair market interest rate
each year right
so the short answer the question of how
do i price floating rate bonds is
if they're priced right you should price
them at par to the extent that the reset
of the interest rate is not perfect
you're not getting a perfect reason to
the market interest rate
the mark the value of a floating rate
bond might not be
quite par value but it's never going to
vary as much as an otherwise similar
fixed rate wants
so i know this is bond pricing 101 there
are lots of
shades of gray we haven't looked at but
the mechanics of what we've talked about
illustrates how time
value of money and understanding the
coup and understanding the basics of
default spread are sufficient
in order to price or value a bond